I I was quite frustrated so I thought
look I'm going to turn up half an hourly
um just to sort of try to get that mind
game in early because at the end of the
day chess is a mind game and it it's
quite frustrating when you've got all
this pent-up uh energy and you're
waiting for your opponent to turn up
because it's like come on I just want to
play did you see that I didn't wow guys
just did a handshake just up in the air
without an opponent
oh really I didn't see that I I missed
that oh no I don't know if you can get
an action replay of that of it but I
haven't seen that happen before uh but
ninja tabasov does arrive there is a 15
minute Rule and I think you are fine but
I'm gonna get a confirmation on this but
if you arrive late for the match you are
fine uh by fide and if you arrive after
15 minutes of the block starting that's
a four feet you lose the the game